[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous
sommes le mercredi 23 novembre voici le
programme à la une de l'actualité la
sobriété énergétique avec l'explosion du
coup des énergies les communes les
entreprises et les Yvelinois se
mobilisent pour réduire leur
consommation et pour trouver des
solutions nous en parlerons avec nos
invités Xavier de Laporte du club climat
énergie de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
Marc Fleury directeur territorial
d'enedis dans les Yvelines pour répondre
à la problématique des déserts médicaux
le département des Yvelines s'est lancé
dans la télémédecine il vient de signer
un partenariat avec l'entreprise HKD qui
crée des cabines de téléconsultation
alors comment ça fonctionne S comme en
présentiel Valérie cosita directrice
générale de HKD répondra à nos questions
et le mercredi c'est le jour de notre
page cinéma nous parlerons des films à
ne pas manquer dans les prochains jours
she said bones and all Saint-Omer ce
sera avec notre journaliste Céline
Charles au programme également le coup
de cœur d'un professionnels du septième
art et avec moi en plateau également
Régine relay bonsoir journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 vous allez nous
parler de ce qu'il s'est passé dans les
Yvelines aujourd'hui oui alors comme
tous les jours il s'est passé énormément
de choses on va parler notamment de
Jamel Debbouze mais aussi du Pass Navigo
et aussi de la sobriété énergétique ce
sera juste après mais avant j'en parlais
à l'instant la sobriété énergétique est
au cœur des problématiques actuelles et
avec nous pour en parler Marc Fleury
bonsoir bonsoir alors je le disais vous
êtes le directeur territorial d'enediste
dans les Yvelines est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre cet hiver à des coupures
d'électricité elle est dit ce travail
avec RTE et des pouvoirs publics pour
limiter le risque de coupure c'est notre
raison d'être c'est notre mission de
service public et effectivement si les
prévisions de RTE se confirment il est
possible qu'on est en recours en dernier
recours à quelques quelques coupures de
quelques délestages et donc on en
parlera plus en détail dans quelques
instants avec nous également Xavier
Delaporte bonsoir bonsoir alors je le
rappelle aussi vous êtes le président du
club climat énergie
le directeur du coup le directeur du
club climat énergie de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines quelles sont les solutions
qu'on peut facilement mettre en place
pour réduire sa facture énergétique
alors facile je sais pas en tout cas moi
j'aurais tendance à répondre à un peu
comme mon voisin il faut anticiper
aujourd'hui si on veut réduire ses
consommations d'énergie c'est pas au
dernier moment qu'on s'y prend il faut
essayer de maîtriser ce qu'on appelle
faire maîtriser ses consommations
d'énergie donc déjà les connaître
son on ne connaît pas c'est consommation
d'énergie c'est très difficile de mettre
en place les bonnes actions il s'agisse
d'isolation de changement d'équipement
des cogestes parce que derrière tout ce
qu'on va mettre en place ça dépendra
vraiment de du mode de consommation je
dirais de l'entreprise ou éventuellement
des particuliers c'est c'est
pareils aussi un peu plus tard avec nous
également un plateau Valérie cosita
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice générale
de HKD donc c'est une société qui permet
aux médecins de pouvoir consulter leur
patient à distance concrètement comment
est-ce que ça fonctionne c'est tout
simple
c'est tout simple en fait c'est un
dispositif médical donc très sérieux
certifié enfin il y a des nombreuses
sécurité certification donc vous entrez
en fait on a essayé de recréer le
colloque singulier c'est-à-dire le tête
à tête entre le médecin et le patient
dans une cabine de télémédecine qui a
été créée par un médecin la société a
été fondée par un médecin donc on a
vraiment cette vision médicale à tous
les tous les
points du processus et donc du coup le
patient prend un rendez-vous sur
immédiance.com ensuite arrive donc il
voit la localisation choisi la
localisation seront dans une cabine de
thé médecine qui peut être en
collectivité en centre de santé qui peut
être dans un hôpital aussi
dans une entreprise il y a aussi des
entreprises qui s'équipent pour leurs
salariés et il arrive
donc il a un petit code sur par SMS
quand le code accède à la cabine en
général on met aussi un accueil humain
parce que l'humain est quand même
fondamental donc ensuite il rentre sa
carte vitale dans la machine c'est pris
en charge et à ce moment-là pareil
pareil sauf qu'on met la carte vitale au
début à la fin et ensuite dès qu'on a
mis la carte Vitale le médecin apparaît
sur les grands donc c'est un véritable
médecin donc dès qu'on rentre dans la
cabine qu'on a inséré sa carte Vitale on
est pris en charge par un médecin
du déploiement de la télémédecine dans
les Yvelines un tout petit peu plus tard
en plus en détail dans cette émission
nous reviendrons aussi sur le premier
match de l'équipe de France face à
l'Australie lors de la Coupe du monde
c'était d'hier soir mais avant je tends
un petit coup d'œil à la météo de demain
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
devait être nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera à 8 degrés en moyenne mais avec
un ressenti de 4 degrés dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
avec des rafales devant allant jusqu'à
45 km/h au niveau des températures il
fera 12 degrés en moyenne et demain nous
fêterons les florales le point
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines
et c'est avec vous réginer
en fait mardi 22 novembre Valérie
Pécresse a annoncé la hausse du prix du
Pass Navigo en 2023 donc actuellement le
prix est de 75 euros 20 mais il passera
de 4 à 80 euros et 80 centimes ou 90
euros c'est au gouvernement de tranchées
une personnalité s'est rendue à trappe
aujourd'hui oui et c'est le comédien
Jamel Debbouze qui est allé à la
rencontre des collégiens des élèves du
collège pardon le village et on le
rappelle d'ailleurs Jamel Debbouze qui
est originaire de la ville de trappes et
qui a fait ses premières armes à la
compagnie de théâtre des clics et on
continue de parler de Trappes régime
effectivement alors on continue à parler
de Trappes donc la ville fait partie des
90 collectivités territoriales qui
s'engage à réduire leur consommation
énergétique pour parvenir à cet objectif
elle se bat justement sur un dispositif
qui se nomme Ecowatt c'est un dispositif
d'alerte qui informe en temps réel les
Français sur leur niveau de consommation
et du coup cela a été décidé hier lors
du Salon des mers apporte de Versailles
le chiffre du jour c'est 145000 euros
pourquoi alors 145000 euros c'est
l'indemnisation qui est versée au 28
agriculteurs Yves Linois si vous vous
souvenez le 4 juin dernier une tempête
de grêle sabattait dans le sud du
département et les intempéries avaient
causé d'énormes dégâts notamment à
Rambouillet ou des de chant avait été
ravagé du sport à présent avec cette
petite bombe lâchée par le président du
PSG alors oui Paris mérite un meilleur
stade c'est la phrase prononcée par
Nasser Al relaifi depuis le Qatar où se
tient la Coupe du monde le Paris
Saint-Germain envisage justement de
quitter son antre historique du Parc des
Princes en cause un prix trop élevé
demandé par la Mairie de Paris pour le
rachat du stade effectivement donc le
club souhaite agrandir le stade de 48
000 à 60 000 places en cas d'échec dans
ce projet le PSG tout se tournerait vers
d'autres pistes alors racheter le Stade
de France à Saint-Denis ou bien
construire un nouveau stade et la ville
de Poissy est évoquée comme potentiel
site c'est d'ailleurs là-bas que le
Paris Saint-Germain construit son futur
centre d'entraînement et on termine avec
une info consommation effectivement si
vous ne savez pas où réparer votre
voiture ou faire votre révision j'ai une
bonne nouvelle le magazine spécialisé
auto plus vient de désigner le meilleur
garage des Yvelines qui se nomme ad
Autodistribution et se place à
Rambouillet dans la ZAC du Bel-Air le
garage option une note de 9,9 sur 10
grâce à la satisfaction client la
qualité d'intervention et à ses prix
attractifs
de ce garage merci virginralex et si
vous aussi vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous le communiquer en
utilisant le hashtag cette fuite news
où jeter un papier un mouchoir
usagé peut-on mettre les restes de
poissons au compost comment limiter le
gaspillage l'auteur Guillemette
resplendid taille vient de sortir le
petit guide du recyclage le voici un
livre qui fait écho en pleine semaine
européenne de la réduction des déchets
il permet notamment de mieux faire
comprendre aux enfants l'origine des
matériaux et où vont les déchets
lorsqu'on les jette
récoltés par Julien Leroy
[Musique]
j'ai voulu insister surtout sur
faire connaître aux enfants les
matériaux avant qu'ils sachent comment
s'en débarrasser comment les les
recycler parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
très vite qu'il y avait une grande
méconnaissance même des matériaux les
plus simples
[Musique]
on fait des petits ateliers tout simple
et puis on regarde en gros ce qu'on a
sur soi puis se rendre compte aussi ben
ce qu'on a il y a aussi des fermetures
éclairées en métal il y a des boutons en
plastique ou en bois ou en liège et puis
nos tissus ont été teints et puis on a
rajouté un petit peu d'élastique pour
avoir un jean beaucoup plus confortable
donc en fait c'est toute une évolution
pour faire comprendre aux enfants que
tout n'est pas acheté par exemple dans
le plastique et aussi que ça ne va pas
se recycler la même manière selon qu'on
est un pull en laine
naturelle ou des fibres synthétiques
[Musique]
le tissu ça peut être pour refaire des
chiffons pour faire des isolants des
isolants à la maison mais aussi au
niveau industriel et puis ne pas oublier
bien sûr que les les vêtements peuvent
servir à d'autres et ça peut donc être
vendu ou encore mieux donner
[Musique]
il faut aussi qu'ils comprennent
pourquoi leurs parents ou leurs
grands-parents en fait ont tellement
apprécié d'avoir ces nouveaux matériaux
parce qu'il faut pas non plus qu'on
devienne dans une aire ou en fait on est
en train de tout critiquer
en disant mais ils ont fait que du mal
on ouvre une large page sur la crise
énergétique à présent la production et
la consommation d'électricité s'annonce
tendue durant cet hiver face à cette
situation exceptionnelle le gestionnaire
du réseau électrique français RTE en
partenariat avec l'Agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie ont mis en place l'application
ecowat les détails avec Gwenaëlle
Lemarchand référente exploitation
Île-de-France pour RTE
[Musique]
on a une disponibilité très basse du
parc nucléaire avec quasiment un
réacteur nucléaire sur deux à l'arrêt on
a aussi une vigilance particulière sur
notre capacité à importer de
l'électricité depuis les pays voisins et
ça c'est lié à la crise énergétique
russe et à l'alimentation en gaz on
anticipe une possibilité de devoir
couper la consommation des Français pour
pour garantir cet équilibre production
égale consommation et donc on s'apprête
à passer un hiver exceptionnel avec une
vigilance vraiment exceptionnelle sur
l'ensemble de la période hivernale
on a développé un site internet mon
ecowatt.fr on a développé également une
application Ecowatt qui va permettre à
chacun d'adapter sa consommation
d'électricité en fonction de la météo de
l'électricité et qui reflétera le niveau
de tension du système électrique pendant
tout l'hiver
[Musique]
deux volets dans ecowatts le premier
violet c'est une la météo de
l'électricité sous forme de signaux vers
orange ou rouge et qui permettront à
chacun de savoir pour la journée en
cours et pour les trois journées à venir
le niveau de risque du système
électrique signal vert tout va bien
signal orange quand on fait la somme de
ce que tous les Français vont consommer
les particuliers les collectivités les
entreprises on se rapproche de la
capacité de production maximale
disponible en France et puis éco-watt
rouge signale rouge c'est que là par
contre quand on prévoit la consommation
des Français on va dépasser le niveau de
production maximum disponible en France
et donc là il y a un risque fort d'être
obligé de couper les Français de couper
particulier collectivités entreprises
pour arriver à retrouver un équilibre du
système
[Musique]
Nicolas dondry bonsoir vous êtes venus
nous rejoindre un plateau vous allez
nous parler de la sobriété énergétique
on vient de l'entendre la situation est
assez exceptionnelle cet hiver notamment
au niveau de la consommation d'énergie
et au niveau notamment de l'électricité
et les entreprises sont aussi concernées
et donc je vais vous parler de la
sobriété énergétique dans les
entreprises des mesures qui ont déjà été
mises en place mais aussi des mesures à
venir et c'est quelque chose aussi c'est
un sujet qui sera abordé ce vendredi
dans notre numéro du Cay Eco on aura on
a rencontré notamment Xavier de la Porte
qui est en plateau avec nous et qui
intervient dans le skyco n'aura aussi
anne-faye en interview on est allé aussi
dans l'entreprise airwell qui est
spécialisée dans la dans les productions
de climatisation mais qui se développe
de plus en plus maintenant notamment
dans le photovoltaïque un programme
riche mais juste avant on va revenir un
petit peu sur ces mots qu'on a entendu
là le risque de coupure d'électricité
est bien présent cet hiver marque Fleury
je le rappelle vous êtes le directeur
territorial d'enedis dans les Yvelines
quelle est la procédure à suivre si on
veut mettre en place un délestage alors
on travaille maintenant RTE et en charge
de la prévision parce qu'il faut
anticiper ces contraintes sur le réseau
et donc
si d'aventure les gestes ne sobriété
énergétique ne sont pas suffisantes si
les gestes pourraient faire enedis pour
soulager la contrainte ne sont pas
suffisantes en dernier recours on
pourrait effectivement envisager des
processus de délestage et ça on le saura
qu'à J-3
ciblée localisée sur une période
maximale de deux heures qui sera qui est
là pour faciliter le passage des pics de
consommation qui sont sur les périodes 8
heures 13 heures 18 heures 20 heures
donc on est vraiment sur certains pics
de consommation et ça sera on réagira en
fonction du signal Ecowatt que proposera
RTE ce signal sera proposé à l'avance et
donc ça permettra à l'ensemble des les
citoyens français de faire un effort
collectif de sobriété qui nous permettra
peut-être de pas recourir à ce dernier
geste qui est le téléthet stage
justement on a vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'inquiétudes de la part des Français de
la part des entreprises par rapport à
ses coupures d'électricité mais il faut
bien le préciser c'est que deux heures
finalement dans la journée qui aurait
des coupures c'est pas plus
effectivement en fait c'est sa réponse à
un critère technique de choix de deux
heures c'est des procures de dressage
des procédures de sauvegarde du
dispositif pour éviter que le système
électrique n'aille vers une panne un peu
plus généralisée mais il y a des
personnes seront prévenues qui aura eu
des coupures c'est pas des coupures
surprises ou sans prévisions quoi alors
effectivement en France on a l'habitude
d'avoir une qualité de fourniture très
bonne je rappelle que la qualité
d'émotion électrique est à 99,9%
présente en France on a un critère d'un
taux d'animation très bon et donc la
coupure est peu dans nos vue dans nos
vies de tous les jours et donc là
effectivement ce sera des coupures qui
seront anticipées
parce que RTE nous fera nous passera à
l'information et à partir de J-3 ce
qu'on veut pas anticiper trop trop tôt
parce que en fait ça dépend aussi
beaucoup de la météo et des capacités de
production ça dépend aussi de la
capacité des gens à appliquer les bons
gestes des bons gestes sobriété et par
rapport à ça à partir de en place tout
un dispositif commun et RTE pour
communiquer et informer les différents
clients les différents utilisateurs du
réseau sur ce risque potentiel tous les
jours en fait on va confirmer un peu ce
risque à partir de J-3 et avoir une
communication adaptée en fonction des
profils de clients et alors est-ce que
vous pouvez couper le courant
l'électricité dans n'importe quelle zone
ou il y a des zones où vous ne pouvez
pas s'interdire alors en fait il y a que
deux segments de de clients tous les
clients sont logés à la même en scène
j'ai envie de dire parce que dans le
dispositif de délestage il y a pas de
discrimination il y a juste une liste de
clients prioritaires qui est fixé
conjointement avec tes pouvoirs publics
comme je l'expliquais au début en
travaillant en main dans la main pour
ce sont les clients 10 prioritaires
choisis par le préfet qui ne peuvent pas
quelque part il y aurait des risques à
les couper deux heures et donc c'est
quelques clients comme les centres
hospitaliers ou les activités qui sont
liées à la Défense nationale par exemple
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé
sixte particulier une année particulière
alors dans notre dans le cas de service
public enedis RTE et le port public on
charge de d'assumer une bonne sécurité
du réseau électrique donc ça c'est notre
travail de tous les jours qui se voit
pas comme je dis parce qu'il y a peu de
coupure donc à chaque à chaque hiver en
fait on regarde si quel est le risque
entre l'équipe production et
consommation et pour l'hiver 2022 2023
comme la production comme l'a dit ma
collègue drte la production et moins
moins présente il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilant à la consommation
notamment au pic de consommation et donc
le but c'est de passer ses pics
collectivement pour limiter les
contraintes sur le système juste une
question aussi par rapport aux zones
donc par exemple dans les Yvelines
est-ce que il y a certaines communes que
enfin vous savez déjà que dans certaines
communes il y aura pas de coupure
d'électricité non ça on le saura pas
parce qu'effectivement RTE en charge
l'équilibre globale du système et peut
nous demander alors ça rajoute un peu
dans la technique je suis désolé mais
par bloc de 100 mégawatts qui représente
à peu près 50 000 à 100 000 clients
de délester sur tel ou tel secteur mais
on le saura pas avant parce que c'est
bien équilibre global du système qui est
recherché parce qu'en fait quand on
parle de coupure électricité c'est pas
une commune on parle pas à l'échelle
d'une commune c'est des coupures
d'électricité par quartier comment ça
fonctionne en fait donc en fait ça
dépend beaucoup du de la structure du
réseau électrique pour essayer de
schématiser et de faire assez simple on
a des agences de conduite régionale qui
sont la tour de contrôle 24 sur 24 de
l'état du réseau ces agences de conduite
ont des systèmes de télécommande sur le
réseau et ouvre ce qu'on appelle dans
notre langage un peu technique des
départs sur la haute tension et quand on
ouvre ce départ sur la haute tension
tous les clients sur ce départ sont
coupés et donc ça peut être sur
plusieurs communes et peut-être même que
dans une commune il peut y avoir des
clients qui vont voir passer cette
coupure de deux heures ce téléstacle 2h
et d'autres qui le verront pas en
fonction du schéma d'alimentation
électrique
et là sur les prévisions ça peut arriver
à quel moment ces coupures vous le savez
pas alors ce qu'on essaie anticiper au
maximum donc comme j'ai dit c'est notre
travail de tous les jours et avec RTE
produit tous les mois son rapport sur le
niveau de risque et le niveau de risque
il évalue avec deux choses quelle est la
probabilité d'avoir un hiver très froid
qui du coup agit sur le comportement de
la consommation et quel est le niveau de
production et quels sont les les moyens
de production qui sont sur le réseau
avec forcément aussi le la production
nucléaire qui est regardé très près avec
les conditions de retour du nucléaire
donc RTM ils sont rapport là la réalité
à mi-novembre a priori le système
tiendrait sur le décembre et pour
l'instant en fonction des retours de la
production il pourrait y avoir quelques
jours signe rouge et covoits qui
nécessiterait une vigilance particulière
sur le mois de janvier merci d'être venu
en parler avec nous en plateau je le
rappelle vous êtes le directeur
territorial d'enedis dans les Yvelines
pour aller plus loin sur le sujet de la
crise énergétique vous vous êtes
intéressé Nicolas au sujet de la
sobriété énergétique dans les
entreprises oui effectivement Mathilde
hier soir j'étais au ski cube 50 ans en
Yvelines organisé une réunion sur ce
sujet une réunion d'information sur la
sobriété énergétique des entreprises
objectif répondre aux questions des
dirigeants en exposants notamment le
contexte actuel de la crise énergétique
et on écoute à ce propos Jean-Marc
Dubreuil associé de l'entreprise wat
value spécialisé dans la gestion des
contrats d'énergie alors la situation
actuelle est complètement imprévisible
complètement nouvelle d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup beaucoup de consommateurs et
explosive pour le niveau des contrats
d'énergie que vont devoir signer les les
consommateurs sur l'année 2023 et
au-delà elles vont se retrouver avec une
augmentation de leur budget de 2 3 4 5
fois et elles doivent impérativement
signer leur contrat le plus rapidement
possible pour bénéficier au maximum de
tous les amortisseurs qui ont été mis en
place par l'État
et alors comment les entreprises
doivent-elles faire face à cette
situation Nicolas alors écoutez Mathilde
plusieurs aides ont été mises en place
par les pouvoirs publics et qui sont
destinés aux entreprises alors j'en ai
retenu trois le bouclier tarifaire qui
sera prolongé en 2023 pour les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés avec
un chiffre d'affaires inférieur à 2
millions d'euros pour ces sociétés là où
se débrie de l'électricité sera limitée
à 15 % à partir du 1er décembre les
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
pourront bénéficier du chèque efficacité
énergétique de la région
Île-de-France une aide jusqu'à 5000
euros pour investir mais dans des
solutions pour justement réduire la
consommation d'énergie dernier
dispositif que j'ai retenu le flash diag
énergie proposé par la Chambre de
Commerce et de l'Industrie c'est un
autodiagnostic en ligne pour identifier
des leviers d'action pour réduire sa
consommation d'énergie mais pour plus
d'informations en fait vous pouvez
consulter ce fascicule qui a été créé
par Saint-Quentin en Yvelines qui
répertorie tous les dispositifs
d'accompagnement pour les entreprises et
vous pouvez le télécharger sur le site
internet de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
peut-être que vous pouvez lever un un
petit peu plus haut voilà comme ça on le
voit mieux donc consultable sur internet
téléchargeable sur internet sur le site
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et on
écoute anne-faye la directrice adjointe
au développement économique à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous avons
deux retours de la part des entreprises
évidemment de voir comment maîtriser la
facture énergétique et d'avoir
l'ensemble des dispositifs des aides qui
sont prévues de façon à ce qu'elle
puisse les mobiliser et puis le deuxième
sujet également qui qui l'immobilise
c'est comment accompagner leur salarié
dans
l'adoption de toutes les mesures
d'efficacité énergétique et là encore 50
ans de les villes est aux côtés des
entreprises pour leur apporter des
conseils en matière de bonnes pratiques
alors il y a déjà de nombreuses
entreprises et Xavier de la Porte pourra
nous en parler des entreprises de 50 ans
en Yvelines qui ont mis en place des
solutions qui sensibilisent aussi leurs
collaborateurs mais vous avez aussi
l'exemple du centre commercial de
Westfield Parly 2 qui a signé une charte
de sobriété énergétique avec ses
commerçants pour mettre en place un plan
de réduction de la consommation
énergétique de 20% par rapport à 2019
plusieurs mesures concrètes vont dans ce
sens un maintien à 17 degrés de la
température une réduction de 30% de
l'éclairage ou encore l'extinction
complète du centre et du parking en
dehors des horaires d'ouverture alors
justement je parlais de Xavier de
Laporte donc directeur du club climat
énergie aujourd'hui comment quel conseil
vous donner aux entreprises pour
justement rentrer dans un plan de
sobriété énergétique alors déjà quand on
parle de sobriété énergétique derrière
il y a un autre mot qui est l'économie
qui le coulent l'énergie donc pour
pourquoi je dis ça parce que la sobriété
c'est la motivation
est-ce que la motivation elle vient de
se dire je veux simplement réduire ma
consommation d'énergie parce que parce
qu'on en parle ou parce que tout
simplement je voudrais dire ma facture
ma facture d'énergie dans les
entreprises c'est fondamental les prix
sont aujourd'hui un tel niveau que de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix donc
maintenant le par rapport à votre
question le vrai enjeu c'est des motiver
les salariés on les impliquant dans la
réflexion de l'entreprise et il y a rien
de tel que un salarié motivé pour
pouvoir appliquer certains éco-gestes
qui sont pas tous uniques il y en a
plusieurs entreprises ça peut aller tout
simplement de d'éteindre des lumières ça
peut être de faire attention dans les
salles de réunion ajouter un exemple au
cas où on pensera rarement c'est de
mettre des capteurs des salles de
réunion souvent elles sont alimentées
elles sont il y a de la lumière elles
sont allumées et parfois ça sert tout
simplement à rien
des capteurs de présence sont des choses
qui sont pas très cher pas très
onéreuses mais qui sont très efficaces
vous voyez après dans les entreprises il
y a aussi des systèmes de pilotage qui
sont extrêmement intéressants de
régulation des températures de
régulation des consommations d'énergie
tout ça ce sont des gestes et des
actions qui sont complémentaires il y en
a pas une et sur la partie vraiment
sobriété je pense plus particulièrement
aux éco-gestes je pense à l'émulation
c'est à dire et nous du coup je fais le
lien avec 50 ans en Yvelines et le club
on va lancer un challenge écho énergie
tertiaire dans lequel on va vouloir
impliquer l'ensemble des salariés qui le
voudront bien pour les bâtiments pour
les entreprises qui voudront jouer le
jeu à appliquer des éco-gestes
n'est pas là pour leur dire ce qu'il
faut faire c'est leur entreprise c'est
leur fonctionnement mais derrière on
prendra la consommation d'énergie fin
2022 on regardera fin 2023 et on verra
quels sont les écarts mais croyez moi
quand on fait un challenge il y a rien
de tel pour motiver les acteurs et à
faire des gestes quels sont les autres
solutions qu'on peut mettre en place
Marc Fleury alors vous avez de la porte
à raison en fait pour agir il faut
pouvoir mesurer et j'ai envie de dire
que la France dispose à ce titre d'un
outil incroyable c'est l'outil Linky qui
permet de bien mesurer sa consommation
d'énergie alors nous on l'a déployé donc
effectivement on en fait ça sa publicité
on pense qu'il peut apporter beaucoup
mais l'ADEME dit que à partir du moment
où on commence à s'intéresser à sa
consommation d'énergie on va faire une
économie de 10% d'énergie donc c'est
c'est très important et c'est vraiment
le premier palier qui est fixé par le
gouvernement en termes de sobriété
énergétique et encore une fois le but
c'est pas de de
comment dire de culpabiliser les gens
c'est plutôt de les rendre attentifs
alors consommation d'énergie et
peut-être de décaler leurs usages pour
justement mieux permettre de passer ces
pics de consommation énergétique et
c'est pics journaliers on a un réseau de
grande qualité le réseau et le système
électrique en français de grande qualité
on a une petite période de tension liée
à diverses typique de consommation si on
décale on va on va on aura aucun
problème sur le système électrique dans
son ensemble et alors Xavier delaborde
demain vous allez mener une conférence
sur l'hydrogène intitulé quelles sont
les perspectives pour l'hydrogène est-ce
que ça se développe de plus en plus
l'hydrogène alors les rejets c'est un
vaste sujet qui passionne beaucoup qui a
manifestement un bel avenir la question
c'est quel type de venir faut simplement
repréciser quoi sert l'hydrogène les
gens même d'abord c'est un vecteur
d'énergie ça permet de passer d'énergie
primaire ce que va être technique vers
des usages finaux donc transformer une
énergie pour pour un usage l'hydrogène
c'est aussi un gaz qui existe qu'on
utilise en réalité depuis très c'est pas
une si grande nouveauté simplement
aujourd'hui la complication c'est son
coût de production et les coûts sont
largement supérieurs on parle de par 3
par rapport aujourd'hui aux autres
technologies donc si demain on veut
utiliser de l'hydrogène il faut trouver
le moyen de réduire les coûts dans la
réduire les coûts ça il y a des
réflexions et c'est peut-être une vraie
opportunité qui nous a offert à nous la
France mais globalement à l'ensemble je
dirais des acteurs énergétiques puisque
il y a une crise éternelle énergétique
peut-être accélérons alors je parle pas
de subvention est-ce qu'il faut souvent
suivre ou pas la réponse est
certainement oui mais en tout cas de
développer des nouveaux systèmes et des
innovations pour être capable de
produire de l'hydrogène moins cher par
exemple alors quand je parle d'hydrogène
je rajoute d'hydrogène divers c'est à
dire décarbonée parce que sinon
évidemment ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué et si on
parle d'hydrogène de carbulé on pense
notamment à l'installation de de
photovoltaïque de panneaux
photovoltaïques le seul X il faut en
prendre beaucoup des très grandes
quantités pour être capable de produire
suffisamment d'hydrogène pour que ce
soit intéressant je crois peut-être y
revenir après sur ce sujet là c'est une
solution par rapport à la crise actuelle
qu'on vit la crise énergétique parce que
vous dites que finalement ça réduit pas
les coûts en énergie et aujourd'hui la
problématique alors oui il y a le
réchauffement climatique mais c'est
aussi une problématique de prix
aujourd'hui surtout mise en avant par
les entreprises mais aussi par les
particuliers oui c'est une logique de
prix c'est aujourd'hui on réfléchit sur
l'hydrogène on réfléchit sur ces
applications on réfléchit comment quels
sont les usages et ça c'est déterminant
le l'hydrogène aujourd'hui il faut pas
oublier les choses c'est que c'est 80%
dans l'industrie c'est pas encore
utilisé à 50 ans de limites même si on
le souhaiterait l'hydrogène est plutôt
réservé à des usages bon je disais
industriels mais si on parle de mobilité
plutôt de mobilité lourde on n'est pas
trop sur le véhicule léger parce que
c'est pas c'est trop cher c'est
difficile à stocker et puis c'est c'est
difficile à non ce qu'il faut voir sur
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui c'est l'objet
d'ailleurs de la conférence que nous en
lançons demain à la Banque Populaire Val
de France c'est l'hydrogène dans 10 ans
mais si on veut en 2030 avoir un
hydrogène qui soit compétitif et donc
des solutions de production et de
consommation qui soit efficiente il faut
commencer dès maintenant et les 8 ans
qui nous séparent de 2030 grosso modo et
puis de l'ensemble de la réflexion
énergétique c'est pas trop croyez-moi il
y a beaucoup d'acteurs qui sont et tant
mieux ça va créer l'innovation ça va
créer de l'émulation après je j'aurais
tendance à dire j'attendrai 2030 pour
vous dire si c'est si c'est la solution
mais en tout cas tout le monde y croit
et on ne peut que que s'y intéresser en
tout cas et dans quelle filière est-ce
qu'on peut développer l'hydrogène
justement vous avez parlé un petit peu
de l'industrie lourde l'industrie
manière générale c'est on produit
beaucoup d'améliaque c'est 45% auprès de
la production d'hydrogène c'est aussi
toute la partie raffinerie et après les
autres usages sont un peu plus exotiques
aujourd'hui on se pose la question de
produire de de l'hydrogène parce que
l'hydrogène derrière grâce à une pile à
combustible permet de produire de
l'électr donc c'est là qu'on réfléchit à
des usages de type mobilité est-ce qu'on
parle de mobilité légère aujourd'hui
c'est je le disais c'est très cher donc
c'est pas forcément très intéressant
quand on parle d'hydrogène en fait on
parle de véhicule électrique c'est en
une sorte de prolongation de l'autonomie
électrique alors je pars entrer dans le
débat batterie hydrogène ce sera
peut-être le notre discussion qui sera
certainement passionnante mais
aujourd'hui on pense plutôt à des poids
lourds ou alors pourquoi pas des bennes
ordures ou des engins
c'est que ce sont des véhicules qui
consomment beaucoup mais qui ont surtout
besoin de recharger très vite et là
l'hydrogène est une bonne solution si
vous aviez un véhicule électrique vous
avez un problème de temps de
rechargement oui et là ça répond à ces
usages donc si jamais demande de la
développer en priorité les l'hydrogène
soit la partie mobilité ça sera plutôt
sur ces usages là juste peut-être poser
la question aux autres invités enfin
vous êtes sensibilisés vous à cette
énergie l'hydrogène qu'est-ce que ça
vous évoque
l'hydrogène on en entend beaucoup parler
effectivement on le dit ça sera la
question de sa maturité et de son coup
on a évoqué des coûts d'énergie donc ça
sera qui c'est ça qui rendra l'hydrogène
utilisable pour le système électrique en
tout cas après ça peut être une solution
parce qu'aujourd'hui avec l'énergie se
stock pas et donc comme on a un mix
énergétique avec du nucléaire et
d'énergie naturelle renouvelable
peut-être qu'on peut utiliser
l'hydrogène à côté de de cette
production d'énergie renouvelable qui se
fait en fonction du soleil et puis du
vent et donc ça peut être une solution
de stockage mais encore une fois à moyen
long terme et en fonction du de l'impact
économique que certains entrailles dans
le système électrique
vous avez un avis sur cette question
il y a certainement quelque chose enfin
je pense que c'est une des solutions qui
doit qui doit éclore d'ici quelques
années parce qu'on sait bien que le tout
électrique 100% n'est pas la solution
donc vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
justement
electrifa électrique hydrogénaire je
pense qu'il faut de toute façon il y a
une seule solution et qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui on est en phase de
créativité pour trouver des solutions à
la fois économique et le plus naturel
possible et pérenne
bien merci en tout cas Xavier Delaporte
d'être venu en plateau avec nous merci
également Marc Fleury je vous remets mes
remerciements et du coup si vous voulez
participer à cette conférence vous
pouvez vous inscrire sur le site
internet qui s'affiche juste en dessous
on en parlait aussi en début d'émission
le département des Yvelines se lance
dans la télémédecine et vient de signer
un partenariat avec l'entreprise HKD qui
crée des cabines de téléconsultation
Valérie cosita je le rappelle vous êtes
la directrice générale de HKD
concrètement qu'est-ce que le patient
peut faire dans une télécabine il a quoi
à sa disposition il a tout tout en fait
il a il a surtout d'abord un médecin qui
le reçoit un vrai médecin franchiré en
os donc à distance mais qui le reçoit
donc ça c'est important et ensuite vous
avez tous les dis médicaux donc tous les
instruments que le médecin a
habituellement dans son cabinet elles
sont dans cette cabine de télémédecine
jusqu'à quelques instruments de
spécialités comme l'autoscope le
dermatoscope donc on peut faire de l'ORL
on peut faire du généraliste tout ce qui
est médecine de premiers soins en fait
donc par exemple si je suis un peu
malade je touche j'ai des courbatures
j'ai de la fièvre je peux directement
prendre ma température et ensuite c'est
le médecin qui qui me dit quoi faire
exactement et vous pouvez faire en mode
check-up donc en mode autonome donc là
vous avez un tutoriel qui va vous guider
pour utiliser vous-même les instruments
prendre vos températures votre tension
etc ensuite ou alors avec un médecin
donc réellement avec un rendez-vous avec
votre médecin traitant si le
téléconsultes ou avec un autre médecin
si le vôtre le médecin traitant n'est
pas disponible et bien sûr vous utilisez
votre carte Vitale comme en cabinet
médical ça doit demander un petit peu de
pédagogie pour les médecins pour bien
indiquer aux patients ce qu'il faut
faire oui tout à fait tous les médecins
en fait sont formés sont formés de façon
justement à ce qui est très important
c'est l'humain donc finalement ils
savent pratiquer la médecine les
médecins donc ce qui est important c'est
d'accueillir le patient donc c'est
première étape accueillir le patient et
ensuite effectivement ce familiariser
rapidement avec tous les outils
notamment le software qui permet donc le
logiciel qui permet aux médecins de
d'avoir toute la donnée et les prises de
mesures en direct et le secret médical
est gardé et protégé les données
personnelles des patients bien sûr
toutes les toutes les données déjà nous
nous gardons pas les données
individuelles elles sont en guerre des
données anonisées donc en aucun cas
regarder donner individuelles ça c'est
la première chose donc ça se passe
véritablement c'est vraiment une
relation tant financière que médicale
entre le patient et son médecin que nous
ça ne passe pas par nous bien sûr on a
des serveurs enfin tout tout est
sécurisé HDS rgpd
je suis assez fasciné par les questions
de cybersécurité donc forcément ça
touche à ça quand vous voyez le nom
d'attaques qui ont qu'on voit c'est en
hausse exponentielle par rapport au
service public par rapport aux hôpitaux
vous cette sujet de la cybersécurité je
suppose que c'est au moment du
développement de la solution que vous y
avez pensé
c'est d'abord ce sont des données
sensibles ensuite sont des données qui
sont effectivement
très ciblés enfin souvent souvent
inquiéterais beaucoup de monde on va
dire voilà donc forcément oui c'est
quelque chose vraiment on a quelqu'un
qui est dédié à toutes ces questions de
sécurité donc effectivement c'est notre
quotidien je pense aux personnes qui
sont un petit peu éloignées du numérique
est-ce que c'est finalement accessible à
tous c'était les cabines alors oui alors
je dirais que parce que souvent on me
dit et nos seniors alors je dirais en
fait les seniors sont très curieux voilà
ils n'ont pas forcément un smartphone
mais ils sont très curieux ils ont
également besoin d'être suivis donc se
déplacer prend beaucoup de temps pour
eux c'est toute une organisation donc
les clés vraiment les cabines
téléconsultation médicale sont
véritablement utilisés et notre plus
ancien enfin notre plus senioration 92
ans voilà et il est très content et
c'est vrai que j'ai fait j'ai été
présente sur des salons grand public
aussi et effectivement ils ont cette
patience de découvrir ils n'ont pas peur
et ils sont très heureux donc oui un
Verbatim qui me plaît beaucoup c'est une
âme qui dit j'ai retrouvé la
consultation des années 80 alors
s'amusant parce qu'à la fois c'est très
hautement technologique et à la fois
cette sensation de se retrouver
véritablement dans un dialogue avec son
médecin donc il y a vraiment un dialogue
avec le médecin il y a vraiment le
questionnement initial avec les médecins
donc on retrouve cet échange mais en
plus on a ce support technologique je
dirais même hautement technologique qui
vient enrichir finalement le
comment on appelle la consultation alors
pour terminer rapidement combien il y a
de télécabine aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines alors dans les Yvelines on
vient de lancer le projet d'accord donc
là on a un projet pour
on a une première phase donc on va
lancer à peu près une cinquantaine de
cabines de téléconsultation donc il y a
une première phase de dispositif je
dirais pour les Yvelines ensuite de ça
moi il y en aura davantage puisque c'est
un projet qui va tout de même être mené
sur quatre années donc le département
est très engagé et là où vraiment vous
avez je dirais beaucoup de chance
parce que en fait le département a
réellement
voulu une solution qualitative et
pérenne voilà donc il véritablement un
dispositif qui apporte la consultation
médicale de qualité qui s'inscrivent
dans la coordination des soins du
territoire et donc le département a
vraiment fédérer tous les acteurs donc a
d'abord réuni puis fédérer tous les
acteurs pour pouvoir intégrer ces
dispositifs en complément de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui merci voilà merci
Valérie cosita je suis désolé je vous
cause un petit peu parce qu'on est pris
par le temps est-ce que vous êtes allé
regarder le match le premier match de la
de la de l'équipe de France de football
hier soir est-ce que vous l'avez regardé
ou pas
moi j'ai regardé l'intermittence parce
que je faisais j'étais sur un autre un
autre événement mais je l'ai regardé
mais j'ai raté les quatre les quatre
buts
donc je m'en veux mais c'est pas grave
je me rattrape en tout cas hier soir 12
millions de Français étaient au
rendez-vous pour regarder le 1er match
de l'équipe de France de football ils se
sont largement imposés face à Los 13 lit
avec un score de 4 à 1 nous avons vécu
ce match avec des supporters présents à
Bois-d'Arcy le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier et de Michael elle mie d'euros
ce mardi 22 novembre à Bois-d'Arcy c'est
jour de match la ville retransmet la
rencontre de l'équipe de France face à
l'Australie la commune n'a pas hésité à
programmer une soirée malgré les
polémiques autour de l'organisation de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar nous on veut
juste passer un moment festif évidemment
tout ce qui s'est passé au Qatar et les
conditions d'attribution sont assez
compliquées il faut pas obérer les
problématiques de développement durable
et de traitement de tous ceux qui ont
travaillé à la constitution de ces
stades mais là on est face à la
compétition face au sport et on a besoin
de moments de convivialité tous ensemble
et je suis content qu'il y a une grosse
centaine de personnes ce soir pour un
premier match en plein hiver sur le
terrain la France se fait rapidement
surprendre par les Australiens 1 à 0
mais les Bleus réagissent égalisent et
passent devant 2-1 et supporters
présents dans cette salle de la Fabrique
exulte à la pose ils sont confiants
la France qui pousse et je pense qu'ils
vont marquer encore deux un ou deux buts
et je pense ça va passer faut juste bien
défendre en deuxième période la France
continue sur sa lancée arrive à inscrire
deux autres buts Mbappe Giroud font
bondir les supporters artisans de joie
4-1 ce sera le score final je pense que
l'équipe de France sont bien joué il y
avait pas mal de passes et je pense que
avec les nombreux blessés on pouvait pas
s'attendre à mieux l'attaque était
incroyable par contre la défense un peu
moins forte que ça mais du coup j'étais
surpris par le niveau de l'équipe de
France par rapport à ce que je pensais
je suis plutôt rassuré malgré tous les
forfaits que finalement on a quand même
une équipe encore solide et on a espoir
ouais j'espère qu'ils vont aller au
moins jusqu'en demi-finale avant de
penser au demi-finale la France jouera
son deuxième match de poule ce samedi 26
novembre à 16h Bois-d'Arcy retransmettra
à nouveau le match
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par Jack Koné bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'Olympique Sport Club
d'Élancourt je suppose que vous avez
suivi le match hier soir tout à fait
vous en avez pensé quoi écoutez on a eu
peur au début mais heureusement nos
Bleus sont bien rattrapés et ont mis de
l'intensité dans les pas c'est du coup
on a obtenu la victoire donc on est très
content début un petit peu balbuti avec
l'Australie qui marque le premier but
de l'ampleur il y avait quand même pas
mal de nouveaux joueurs de jeunes
joueurs donc du coup malheureusement le
but encaissé lors du premier quart
d'heure c'est une blessure de Hernandez
remplacée par son frère qui l'a bien
remplacé et derrière ils ont redressé la
barre et on a vu quand même un événement
avec le 51e but de Giraud on peut noter
oui Olivier Giroud meilleur buteur de
l'histoire de l'équipe de France ils
rejoint Thierry Henri vos pronostics
pour les Bleus lors de cette Coupe du
monde je dois y aller jusqu'à où je suis
chaud je vais les voir finaliste au
minimum après si on est objectif j'ai vu
l'Espagne en venant et effectivement il
y a quelques belles équipes certaines
vont devoir réagir comme l'Argentine
parce que ça se trouve on va finir par
les rencontrer au prochain tour pas
évident du tout donc je dirais malgré
tout le dernier carré malgré les
blessures répétées
et 12 millions de Français je le disais
était au rendez-vous pour regarder ce
match c'est plus que en 2018 quand ils
ont joué face à l'Australie en 2018 face
lors de la Coupe du Monde de Russie en
fait on est loin du boycott qui était
annoncé
le dessus je veux dire que moi-même
effectivement on n'est pas toujours en
phase avec tout ce qui se passe dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui mais le
je prends le dessus très rapidement on a
assisté à des beaux matchs de belles
rencontres et après ça reste un bel
événement donc du coup je prends que ça
prend le dessus et après c'est pas parce
que qu'on regarde que forcément on
cautionne et du coup ça me paraît
naturel que derrière nos bleus un
maximum de français sur derrière leur
téléviseur au sein de l'OSC et l'encours
est-ce qu'il y a des enguments des
engouement autour de cette coupe du
monde auprès auprès des joueurs et des
dirigeants alors effectivement cette
saison on l'a bien commencé c'est à dire
que au niveau des inscriptions on était
l'année dernière à peu près 630
licenciés 650 et là on va peut-être
atteindre la barre des 800 et je sais
que mes autres collègues dans les clubs
aux alentours
ont aussi augmenté au niveau de leur
licencier donc effectivement c'est
certainement dû à la Coupe du monde et à
l'envie de refaire du foot et du coup
effectivement même là on a un peu décoré
parce que la FFF nous avait envoyé des
petits kits de sur Terre on a décoré le
club house et donc du coup je pense je
vois de plus en plus de maillots de
l'équipe de France sur les terrains
d'entraînement de d'élanco est-ce que
vous allez organiser des soirées pour
regarder les matchs ensemble on y pense
on y pense alors on va attendre qu'on
disait que ils vont peut-être à l'issue
du Tour et
des du tour préliminaire et là peut-être
que effectivement lors des matchs
décisifs en organisera quelque chose
chez nous vous avez combien de de
l'essentiel actuellement au club 766
766 licenciés dirigeant inclus et
effectivement on serait content et fier
de d'atteindre la barre des 800 et c'est
quand même voir 150 de plus que l'année
dernière donc du coup
on est très content de ce nombre de
licenciés et en général une compétition
comme la Coupe du monde ça amène plus de
licenciés alors c'est toujours à l'issue
parce que pour le coup avec la Coupe du
Monde qui est placé dans cette période
de la saison donc du que la saison est
en cours généralement c'est toujours
lors de la peur d'Estival et à l'issue
de la période estivale que les que les
futurs licenciés viennent au club donc
là on est dans un espèce de paradoxe
néanmoins je pense quand même qu'on aura
des des bons retours donc si la France
performe derrière on est probable qu'on
est quelques appels en plus et qu'on ne
voit voir peut-être avec nos partenaires
de la mairie pour qu'il nous donne des
terres supplémentaires ce sera plutôt en
janvier en janvier on risque
effectivement d'avoir un afflux de
joueurs qui veulent venir rejoindre nos
reins
je vous signale que du coup mène cinq à
zéro là votre favori
je le rappelle vous êtes le président de
l'Olympique Sport Club d'Élancourt le
Centre d'histoire culturel des sociétés
contemporaines qu'on appelle aussi le
laboratoire d'histoire de l'UVSQ
organisent à l'occasion de ses 30 ans un
colloque ouvert au public dans les
locaux de l'université c'est du 24 au 25
novembre prochain et parmi les thèmes
abordés lors de ce colloque celui de
l'histoire face au patrimoine Anne
Claude Ambroise rendu directrice du
laboratoire explique à Patrice karmus
les enjeux de ce thème ça c'est un des
axes qui a été développé depuis quelques
années un des axes un peu nouveau du
laboratoire et dans la nouveauté est
accrue par l'intégration dans la notion
de patrimoine du du patrimoine naturel
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui nous nous
travaillons alors oui on peut le dire
comme ça pas tout à fait ça mais on
absolument donc qui nous amène à
travailler à la fois sur les politiques
culturelles qui ont présidé à la
patrimonialisation les monuments etc et
puis également évidemment évidemment
au motifs qui préside à cette
patrimonialisation c'est à dire quand on
crée un patrimoine qui soit culturel ou
naturel qu'est-ce qu'on veut protéger
qu'est-ce qu'on veut préserver qu'est-ce
qu'on comment on trie et qu'est-ce
qu'elle est l'objet quel est le critère
de choix qu'a présidé à la sélection de
cet objet là pourquoi celui-ci est pas
un autre pourquoi cet espace naturel
mérite d'être protégé et pas un autre
qui est juste à côté et qu'est-ce que ça
a comme conséquence de protéger là et
pas là et c'est vrai que oui alors il y
a des patrimoine naturelle mais quand on
parle des des ce qui est retenu comme
patrimoine par leesco par exemple c'est
aussi des pratiques culturelles
voilà pourquoi patrimoine culturel
patrimoine culturel matériel immatériel
d'ailleurs un séminaire sur la
gastronomie il y a beaucoup de
recherches sur la sur les gastronomie
les médias et la médiatisation de la
gastronomie au sein du laboratoire et
vous pouvez retrouver de plus en plus
développement sur les 30 ans du
laboratoire d'histoire sur les enjeux de
l'histoire culturelle dans l'émission
PAF qui est consacrée à ce sujet on va
passer maintenant à notre page cinéma le
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78 nous
a rejoint en plateau bonsoir vous allez
nous parler des sorties cinéma dans
quelques instants quel est le programme
alors au programme cette semaine un film
sur le scandale Harvey Weinstein un
quasi huis clos inspiré de faits réels
le nouveau film du réalisateur de call
me by your name et un film d'animation
japonais et ce sera juste après le coup
de cœur d'un professionnel cette semaine
c'est la réalisatrice Jena sur rue qui
nous parle du film whiplash regardez le
film que je recommande et huit places du
réalisateur
américain Damien Chazel
ce que je trouve formidable dans ce film
c'est déjà à quel point il nous immerge
dans cet univers musical
ou c'est le jazz qui est mis au cœur de
la scène
[Musique]
aussi ce film mais vraiment en scène ce
jeune batteur avec en quelque sorte son
double plus expérimentées plus âgé avec
lequel il vit un rite de passage qui par
certains côtés peut ressembler à une
histoire d'amour puisqu'ils vivent des
obstacles des disputes et une certaine
forme de partage artistique Damien
Chazel est un réalisateur que j'admire
beaucoup et ce film a un travail sur la
lumière notamment je pense à la lumière
qui est travaillée dans le cadre de donc
cette scène de concert pour représenter
les différents rôles entre les musiciens
et aussi le rite de passage de ce jeune
batteur j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
un travail absolument époustouflant et
on reconnaît bien la pâte de Damien
Chazel avec le travelling et les
mouvements de la caméra qui sont
absolument unique en son genre
[Musique]
et on continue de parler cinéma avec
vous Céline Charles vous nous avez
préparé un petit top des sorties de
films au cinéma oui on commence par un
thriller horrifique il s'agit de bonne
scène haul de Lucas Gwada Nino le
réalisateur de call me by your name le
film sorti en 2017 le réalisateur
retrouve d'ailleurs Timothée Chalamet
qu'il avait dirigé dans le film l'acteur
donnera la réplique à Taylor Russell
pour un duo romantique alors
âmes sensible s'abstenir c'est un film
qui pourra en remuer certains c'est
l'histoire de deux jeunes marginaux qui
parcourent les routes américaines à la
recherche de chair fraîche alors oui
vous m'avez bien entendu marraine et lit
son cannibales ou des mangeurs comme on
les appelle dans le film les deux jeunes
tombent amoureux mais sont surtout en
cas de réponse l'absence d'un père ou
encore le désamour d'une mère en fait
c'est surtout le portrait d'une jeunesse
bouillonnante qui cherche sa place dans
un monde qui n'est pas fait pour eux on
se plonge que quelques instants dans
l'univers du film
[Musique]
on va parler d'un film dramatique
maintenant sur les origines de l'affaire
Weinstein exactement she said de Maria
Schrader aborde le scandale de l'affaire
Harvey Weinstein souvenez-vous le 5
octobre 2017 en article d'une New York
Times révélé les stratégies utilisées
par le producteur hollywoodien pour
dissimuler trois décennies de
harcèlement et de crimes sexuel alors
deux reporters du journal en été à
l'origine c'était Jodie Cantor et Meghan
to hay 5 ans après c'est ces deux
journalistes qui deviennent les
personnages principaux du film ce film
dramatique retrace l'enquête qui a mené
à la chute du producteur et qui a permis
au mouvement Mitou de naître regardé
bonjour nous sommes du New York Times
vous avez bien travaillé pour Harvey
Weinstein
certains ont déjà voulu écrire cette
histoire mais à chaque fois il étouffe
l'affaire
toute allégation d'agressions c'est un
maître de la manipulation je vous en
prie donnez-moi la possibilité de vous
parler vous êtes sûr que ces jeunes
femmes ne cherchent pas à coucher avec
un producteur pour lancer leur carrière
ça va au-delà de
là on parle d'un système qui protège les
agresseurs
les femmes qui ont reçu une compensation
financière ne peuvent pas parler elles
seront poursuivies si elles le font mais
si quelqu'un pouvait parler ouvertement
des indemnisations
quelles indemnisation John alors oui
c'est un film qui donne envie d'être
journaliste y compris à ceux qui le sont
déjà effectivement Céline ça donne envie
même d'aller le regarder un film
français maintenant qui retrace aussi
une histoire réelle il s'agit de
Saint-Omer d'Alice Diop un film inspiré
de l'histoire de Fabienne Cabou une mère
condamnée en 2017 pour infanticide sur
sa fille Adélaïde de 15 mois qu'elle
avait abandonné sur une plage dans le
film c'est le personnage de Laurence
colis qui la représente lors d'un quasi
huis clos judiciaire en salle d'audience
on voit défiler témoin juge avocat et
expert la réalisatrice qui avait assisté
au procès à l'époque mais en scène
également Rama une écrivaine et
professeure qui assiste au procès elle
est un peu l'alter ego de d'Alice job de
l'époque Rama est enceinte et se
retrouve bouleversée et confrontée à
certaines questions intimes en écoutant
l'accusé un film d'un autre genre
maintenant il s'agit de inuo un film
d'animation japonais de Massaki USA
c'est le réalisateur du célèbre animé
Devilman cry baby c'est un film qui se
passe au 14e siècle Ino est une créature
maudite née avec une particularité
physique qui l'oblige à cacher son corps
et c'est sous des vêtements et un masque
en marge de la société il va rencontrer
tomona un moine aveugle joueur de Bewa
c'est une sorte de lutte ensemble ils
vont développer une réelle amitié mais
surtout créer un duo rock assez
singulier tomona ou Biwa et Ino à la
danse ils vont petit à petit devenir les
premières célébrités du Japon merci
beaucoup Céline moi je pense que ce que
je préfère ce que je préfère regarder
c'est she said et vous moi aussi
totalement
ça m'intéresse de savoir un petit peu
les dessous de l'affaire qu'on connaît
peut-être pas complètement effectivement
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je vous propose de
regarder un petit coup d'œil à la météo
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
devrait être nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera à 8 degrés en moyenne mais avec
un ressenti de 4 degrés dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
avec des rafales de vent à long jusqu'à
45 km/h au niveau des températures il
fera 12 degrés en moyenne et demain ce
sera la sainte Flora c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
jusqu'au bout avec nous sur TV 78 prenez
soin de vous
[Musique]